do
do
foreign
do
do
so
my name is ruth flynn
you see something wrong we were then
expected to stand up
this year's choice could not be more
clear a steady
experienced public servant who can lead
us out of this crisis just like he's
done before
america we need joe biden no matter
where you come from
or where you're watching from tonight
you have a place
in joe biden's democratic party
a mass people's movement working to
establish
21st century social economic and human
rights
we all have a profound obligation to act
demanding more of our representatives
and our democracy
i nominate my friend joe biden
joe biden joe biden we will stay united
and with our unity
we will bring bold and dramatic change
to our country
now we have an official nominee he does
it for you
joe's purpose has always driven him
forward
we have shown that the heart of this
nation
still beats with kindness and courage
that's the soul of america joe biden
is fighting for now
the democratic party has always risen to
our country's greatest challenges i
pledge myself to a new
deal for the american people we've moved
this country forward in a relentless
push for progress
progress for americans of all walks of
life not just the privileged few
well the harsh facts of the matter are
that we stand at this frontier
at a turning point of history we do not
want our freedom gradually
but we want to be free now we've brought
together voices from every part of
america
we are a people in a quandary about the
present
we are a people in search of our future
we are attempting to fulfill our
national purpose
to create and sustain a society in which
all of us
are equal
and we've made history along the way
there is not a liberal america
and a conservative america there is the
united states
of america we must pledge once more
to march into the future we are a
different society than we were
in 1961. brothers and sisters
do you want to go back
or do you want to keep america moving
forward
well our motto is when they go low we
go high we never bow we never bend
we never break no we endure and we
always
always always move forward
this election we've engaged a historic
number of americans in the democratic
process
and now we have to overcome the odds
once again to build back
better than before we lead not only by
the example of our power
but by the power of our example we are
america
second to none and we own the finish
line
don't forget it
we are democrats and we're ready to lead
again
we're coming together on august 17th all
across america
be there
good evening and welcome to the third
night of the democratic national
convention
last night we nominated our candidate
for president
of the united states joe biden we also
reaffirmed our values
as a party the party of resilience and
hope
empathy and inclusion this is the party
that fired me up
as a young man in the 60s registering
voters
with the student nonviolent coordinating
committee in the mississippi delta
and campaigning for miss fannie lou
hamer for the united states house of
representatives
it's the party that taught me that
public servants
should serve the public even when your
opponents
call you names like nasty or slow
and today it's the party that calls us
to stand up
for what's right and to get in good
trouble so on behalf of this great party
it's my pleasure to welcome once again
delegates alternates standing committee
members friends
and fellow americans members of the
media and guests from around the world
i now call this third session of the
48th quadrennial
national convention of the democratic
party
to order now let's get this show started
and now live from wisconsin please
welcome governor
tony evers
good evening folks i'm tony evers and
i'm incredibly proud
to be the 46th governor of the great
state of wisconsin
we were really looking forward to having
you here in america's dairyland
unfortunately
then pandemic means we can't do that
this year
but what unites us is far far
greater than what divides us so even
though we can't
be with each other i know we have a
shared sense of purpose that is to re
to elect joe biden and kamala harris
this november is about returning
kindness
respect empathy and civility
back to the white house and that's who
joe and kamala are because they know
especially during challenging times like
these
the problems we face can only be solved
by all of us together holy mackerel
folks
let's get to work
hello my name is terry williams and i've
been a republican for all of my adult
life a lifelong republican
republican a lifelong republican i've
been a long-standing republican
and i'm telling you you gotta vote for
joe biden
i have voted for and campaigned for
republicans since the reagan years
but i won't be voting for donald trump
in november i'm supporting joe biden for
president
we need a positive leader someone who
can work
with both sides republicans and the
democrats
i don't think we can deal with the type
of person we have in the white house
any longer vote america that's the only
way to get out of this
and joe biden is just the person to
ensure we get our lives back to normal
joe biden is a decent man with a long
history of public service to america
he will restore order and integrity to
the executive branch
i would strongly encourage all of us to
come together
and hopefully return our country's
political discourse
back to some measure of normalcy and
decency i'm sure
i'm absolutely sure he's going to help
us
bring this country together once again
the united states of america and
the republic for which it stands one
nation
one nation one nation under god
indivisible
with liberty and jesus
hey everybody it's me kamala so before i
go on stage later tonight i want to talk
about the importance of voting
i know many of you plan to vote this
year but admits
the excitement and enthusiasm for this
election
you've also heard about obstacles and
misinformation
and folks making it harder for you to
cast your ballot
so i think we need to ask ourselves why
don't they want us to vote why is there
so much
effort to silence our voices
and the answer is because when we vote
things change when we vote things get
better
when we vote we address the need for all
people
to be treated with dignity and respect
in our country
so each of us needs a plan a voting plan
joe and i want to make sure you're
prepared
if you text vote to 30330
we'll help you come up with your plan
and remember
deadlines and get ready to vote in your
community
so send that text and encourage your
family and friends
to send one to now let's enjoy another
night of inspiration
from around our country i'll see you a
little later tonight and until then
i turn it over to my dear friend and
tonight's moderator
kerry washington
welcome to night three of the democratic
national convention
i'm honored to be joining you as we
continue to celebrate this
unconventional convention we're going to
be hearing a lot more from senator
harris later i
promise but first
when i was in 7th or 8th grade we
memorized
the preamble of the constitution and
i've never forgotten it
the first 15 words of our constitution
are
we the people of the united states in
order to form
a more perfect union we say
more perfect because our union is not
without flaws when our constitution was
written
women couldn't vote black people were
considered
three-fifths of a human being but
therein
lies the work no one is perfect
nothing is but it is the striving toward
justice equality and truth
that distinguishes us we fight for a
more perfect union
because we are fighting for the soul of
this country
and for our lives and right now
that fight is real tonight
we are going to hear from so many
phenomenal women
who are working to help us build that
more perfect union
speaker nancy pelosi secretary hillary
clinton
senator elizabeth warren governor
michelle lujan grisham
we're going to see an incredible
performance from jennifer hudson and a
world premiere performance
from billy eilish we'll meet so many of
the activists and organizers working to
build a more equal more
just future and we're going to hear from
our 44th
president barack obama that's a long way
of saying this is going to be an
unforgettable night filled with
important voices but
the most important voice we hope to hear
from tonight
is the one we need to hear from most
it's yours
because if we are going to repair the
damage
that has been done if we are going to
finally
realize the dream we the people
have to get involved each and every one
of us
is the we you are the we
it's going to be your voice your service
your
action that helps us create that more
perfect union
tonight we're going to talk about where
we are and where we're going
on so many issues important to our
future
ninety percent of americans support
common sense gun laws
because we need to do more to address
the epidemic of gun violence
let's start there
people affected by everyday gun violence
have to walk by the street corner where
their best friend
their brother their mother their nephew
where they themselves were shot
and life goes on and on as if we all
haven't just watched a loved one die and
get put in the grave
the whole point of what i'm saying here
is until one of us or all of us stand up
and say
i can't do this anymore i can't sit by
and watch the news treat these shootings
like acts of god
gun violence isn't just going to stop
until there's a force fighting harder
against it and i'm going to do something
to prevent it
they say that tougher gun laws do not
decrease gun violence
we
they say guns are just tools like knives
we call
bm they say that no laws could have been
able to prevent the hundreds of
senseless tragedies that have occurred
we call bs
that us kids don't know what we're
talking about that we're too young to
understand
how the government works
what we're fighting for will happen
because we're fighting so strongly for
it
we're going to make this change
long before this pandemic our country
has been suffering from the epidemic of
gun violence
gun violence is a public health crisis
one that disproportionately affects the
black and brown communities
first it was my beloved fiance my son
jerry
at the pulse shooting in orlando seven
years later
it would be my son i know exactly the
pain
the toll the heartbreak gun violence
my freshman year my high school went
into lockdown because a kid brought a
gun to school
we've had to endure live shooter
training drills in our schools
high schoolers have enough to deal with
they shouldn't also be responsible for
keeping themselves
safe at school that's the job of the
government we have to end
corporate lobbying by the nra we have to
invest in mental health in our
communities
rather than making our schools maximum
security prisons i want a president
who will make gun violence prevention a
top priority
and i believe joe biden is that person
and now mother and activist deandra
dyches in a split second
a stray bullet shattered my family's
life
my son deandre was only 13 years old
he was recognized as a gifted and
talented student
possibilities were endless he was
dancing at a birthday party
when he was shot in the back left side
of his head
shattering his skull one
shot changed our lives forever
today my dre does not talk he does not
walk
i know he knows me by the smile he shows
when i walk in his room but i'm unsure
if he knows a gunshot has changed his
life
since march i've only been able to see
my son
three times but i can't touch or
hug him due to colbert 19. people tell
me that i'm lucky
i tell them we are blessed i remind them
that my son is in a wheelchair
and unable to feed himself i don't think
deandre feels lucky
when he has to be bathed from head to
toe or gets injections for muscle
contractions
i am in a space of gratitude yes
i can touch deandre i can hold his hand
but the child that i birthed is not able
to live his dreams
and that hurts every day
we're reminded that he may never be the
same
we are not alone in every town across
america
there are families who know what a
bullet can do
that's why i'm a mom who volunteers to
stop
this president trump he doesn't care
he didn't care about the victims after
parkland
las vegas or el paso
i want a president who cares about our
pain
and grief a president who will take on
the gun lobby to ban assault weapons
and close the loopholes to keep guns out
of the hands of criminals
joe biden has taken on the nra twice and
won
and he will do it again as president
i've looked in the eyes of too many
parents
and i mean literally scores of them
who've lost their children to gun
violence
and looked in the eyes of brave young
people who survived school shootings
and i made each of them a promise i made
myself a promise
i promised them and i promise all of you
i will make this promise today
those families hurting across the
country i will never
never
out of pain we choose to find meaning
a glimmer of light that lands on a
promise
former congresswoman gabby giffords
shot in the head from less than three
feet away
but she survived when tragedy strikes
we seek comfort in knowing we aren't
alone join
us in this fight we seek strength
to keep fighting to keep moving forward
we turn to leaders who share our pain
in the most difficult times is when we
stand closest together
it's out of tragedy that we grow
stronger
he was there for me he'll be there for
you too
we are a nation ready to end gun
violence
a safer america is possible
but from this point forward we must
choose courage i've known the darkest of
days days of
pain and uncertain recovery
but confronted by despair i've summoned
hope
confronted by paralysis anesthesia
i responded with grit and a termination
i put one foot in front of the other
i found one word and then i found
another
my recovery is a daily fight but
fighting makes me stronger words
once came easily today i struggle to
speak
but i have not lost my voice
american needs all of us to
speak out even when you
have to fight to find the words
we are at a crossroads we can let the
shooting continue
or we can act we can protect our
families our future
we can vote we can be on the right side
of history
we must elect joe biden
he was there for me he'll be there for
you
too join us in this fight
boat boat vote thank you very much
tonight we're going to hear from many
change makers who are using their powers
for good
who are working to confront the other
epidemics we're facing
covid19 structural racism
police violence against black bodies
violence against members of the trans
community
we are facing so many challenges to meet
these challenges
we will need systematic solutions we
need leaders who can
see us hear us represent us
all of us to joe biden
nothing is more important than taking
the time to make sure that people are
seen heard and believed in
i was interning in dc and i
remember i called my grandmother and i
said joe biden's walking by
and she goes oh my god oh my god put him
on and i see this staffer going like no
no no like don't don't take the call
what are you doing
and he he points to his staff and he
goes like like go that way and he sent
his staffer away
how could i not be endeared to him
instantly
he talked to me for the next half hour i
see dana bash from cnn there
and she says like senator biden will be
on in like five
and he sends her away he asked me about
my sons he asked me about what i did
all i know was it was all about me
not about him and then he comes back to
me then and goes it was lovely talking
to your grandmother
and then he starts the interview with
dana bash it was unbelievable
i must interject one thing at the very
end of his chat with me he said could
you do me a favor
i said sure what is it he said tell me
how i can get your grandson's hair
he wants good humor he was sensitive
and here it is all these years later
and it's visit in my mind you know as
much as i feel like i got to know him in
that moment it feels like he knows
us i know joe because he listens
and whether he's heard your story or
someone else's story
he cares about everyone he'll care
more about you than he'll care about
himself
what a beautiful story okay
now let's talk about another important
issue the climate crisis
this is an issue that has been on joe
biden's mind for decades
in 1986 while working as a senator joe
biden introduced one of the first
climate bills in congress and he's
continued to listen to
and work with climate advocates and
activists putting forward a plan to
address climate change
and create a clean energy economy
there are battles that we need to fight
and we need to win
to secure our future in this country but
there's one issue that is an existential
threat to all of us
and that is climate change the climate
crisis is here and we must act
it is the most pressing issue of our
time and it deserves to be treated as
such
we no longer have any time to wait our
generation will bear
the burden of past mistakes but we stand
to benefit most from changing course now
we know that in a couple of years it
will be too late
we need to change the paradigm and that
happens here with us
we should invest massively win solar
geothermal green infrastructure
moving away from fossil fuels being
highly competitive
in renewables we need to lay out our
specific
policies so that we can give our
children my children your children
a planet that can sustain that needs to
happen now
we need it now the moment demands it we
can afford nothing less
good evening america i'm michelle lujan
grisham governor
of the great state of nuevo mexico i'm
proud of my home state
every single day especially how we have
punched above our weight in our
successful response to covid19
i'm proud of new mexicans from taos to
truth or consequences
who have stepped up and sacrificed in so
many incredible ways
this past half year and i'm proud how we
embrace our multicultural identity
as our greatest strength and i'm proud
that new mexico has shown what climate
leadership looks like
while the trump administration has been
eliminating environmental protections
we've expanded them while they've been
rolling back regulations on oil and gas
we've taken on polluters and held them
accountable
we've committed to a renewable energy
future with exciting and fulfilling
careers
for workers all across our beautiful
state including right here
in the heart of northern new mexico
we're laying a road map here for what
america can
and should look like in the 21st century
in america where we lead again
where we build safer cleaner and more
affordable cities and communities
where we provide meaningful
opportunities for workers
and families to thrive and build better
lives
as president joe biden will rejoin the
international climate agreement
and the united states will once again
lead on this critical issue
at home he'll invest in energy workers
and he will deliver for working families
across the u.s
helping them build meaningful careers
while accelerating our nation and world
into a clean
green 21st century and well beyond
we know time is running out to save our
planet we have the chance this november
to end two existential crises the trump
presidency
and the environmental annihilation he
represents
we have the chance this november to
attack the climate crisis
invest in green 21st century jobs and
embrace the clean energy revolution our
country
our young people are crying out for and
the leadership
the rest of the world is waiting for the
choice
is clear the choice is joe biden
thank you america
hard work rising to a challenge
the american way going to the moon
was all three the ankle had landed many
astronauts returned home
and reported a shift in their awareness
the view they saw of earth from space
was profound the world looked beautiful
tiny fragile our atmosphere
is all that separates us from oblivion
we now call what they experienced the
overview effect
here in detroit our communities for such
a long time have faced the burden
of pollution i think addressing climate
change
gives us an opportunity to correct some
of those wrongs and to also invest in
our vulnerable communities
maybe you've read some of the millions
of pages of scientific evidence on
climate change crushing storm surge or
maybe you felt it as you walked the
neighborhood oh my god the truck is
thinking for most people
it's overwhelming all of this with the
global warming and
that a lot of it's a hoax it's a hoax i
had spent five years working on this
report
the trump administration started to
remove any mention that humans were the
cause of climate change from it
i wrote my resignation letter just six
months into the administration
they were handing the keys of public
lands over to private interests
the trump administration has gone all
out not just to neglect
climate change issues and laws but to
reverse them
we have about a decade before it's too
late
i'm a kid and i'm going to say to all
those adults who are watching this right
now
why don't you get up and do something
some of the first climate change
legislation ever written
was by a senator from delaware when
donald trump thinks about climate change
the only word he can muster is hoax
america faces a challenge but if we face
it together
we will rise to the occasion and build
back better
when i think about climate change word i
think of as
jobs that's joe's plan create millions
of new good
paying jobs many of them union like mine
invest in critical infrastructure
upgrade
millions of buildings invest in micro
mobility
and precision agriculture a clean energy
future
that achieves net zero emissions by 2050
because we can't power the economies of
the future without investing in the
technologies of the future
i think what's really important about
joe biden's plan is that 40
of the investment will go to vulnerable
communities
we know how to do this we'll do it again
but this time
bigger and faster and smarter
joe won't ignore the crisis we're seeing
what happens when we do that
he won't surrender to the fight joe's
america will lead the world on clean
energy
we'll lead on job creation and america
will lead the world again
one climate
i was 13 when the campfire the most
destructive wildfire in california's
history broke out
we were visiting family nearly a hundred
miles away but my asthma flared badly
i could hardly breathe i'm alexandra v
senor
and i've been organizing young people
around climate change since
climate change is impacting us now and
it's robbing my generation of a future
for young people my age every aspect of
our lives
from where we go to school to what kind
of careers we'll have
to whether or not we can raise a family
depends on
us taking climate change seriously right
now joe biden won't solve this crisis in
four years
no one can but he will put us back on
track so that my generation can have a
fighting chance
i'm asking you to join us don't let our
futures go up in flames
the corn growers near my parents farm
have a saying knee-high
by the fourth of july these days they're
lucky if the corn is even planted
because of unpredictable and torrential
spring rains i'm andrew adamski
i studied microbial ecology at northern
michigan university
us farmers can see the effects of
climate change happening right in front
of us
so we've been trying to do our part
we're adopting sustainable solutions on
my family's farm
switching to a community model using
less land and reusing our resources to
grow our food
we are eliminating tons of carbon
pollution every year by mimicking
natural ecosystems
farmers can be part of the climate
solution instead of a problem
today we all can grow our own future but
we need our leaders to be part of the
solution as well
instead of part of the problem we need
them to commit to the science
not ignore it we need them to put real
plans on the table rather than roll them
back
that's what joe biden is doing with his
clean energy revolution
instead of being left behind we could
lead the world again
i spent a lot of time talking about
climate change with different
communities here in nevada
and the one question that i get asked
over and over again is
what are you doing here not a lot of
climate activists look like me
my name is catherine lorenzo i'm an
afro-latina and i'm a climate activist
i grew up in a low-income neighborhood
where pollution rates are often higher
than wealthier areas
and a lot of kids have asthma switching
to renewable energy would mean cleaner
air
better health and a steadier income for
folks in neighborhoods like mine
because solar pv installers and wind
turbines are some of the fastest growing
jobs in the country
and joe biden's plan is transformative
he knows that saving the planet isn't
just a challenge to overcome
it's an opportunity for a better way of
life
so it's going to be america are you
ready to vote for joe biden
are you ready to solve the climate
crisis because our futures depend on it
like the folks we just heard from next
up is another activist
and environmentalist not to mention an
immensely
talented artist she worked to ensure
that her most recent concert tour was
green and sustainable
urging her fans to take similar actions
in their daily lives
and even before she herself was old
enough to vote she held registration
drives before her shows
signing up thousands of voters she's a
voice for her generation in both her
music
and her activism here to perform my
future publicly for the first time billy
eilish
you don't need me to tell you things are
a mess
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything
we care about we need leaders who will
solve problems like climate change and
kovid
not deny them leaders who will fight
against systemic racism
and inequality and that starts by voting
for someone who understands how much is
at stake
someone who's building a team that
shares our values
it starts with voting against donald
trump and for
joe biden silence is not an option and
we cannot sit this one out
we all have to vote like our lives and
the world depend on it because they do
the only way to be certain of the future
is to make it ourselves
please register please vote
i can't seem to focus
and you don't seem to notice i'm not
here
i'm just
you take your complexion
to find your reflections
all alone
can't you hear
me
cause
me
but not with anybody
else just wanna get to
know
know
myself
uh
is
with my future
but not with anybody
here i'll see you in a career
billy eilish thank you
okay now we're going to talk about
something close to my heart
the black community in this country is
hugely
diverse on my father's side i am
descended from african americans
who came from slave ships that landed in
south carolina
and who were part of the great migration
north that has played such a defining
role in who we are as a nation
on my mother's side my grandparents came
here as immigrants
part of a rich history that has also
defined america
they immigrated to this country from the
west indies through ellis island in the
1920s
i often think about how my grandmother
must have felt
when she first saw the statue of liberty
in her raised
torch my family's story is not unique
unless you're native american your
family likely came here from somewhere
else
whether it was five years ago or 200
years ago
whether it was by choice or by bondage
etched into the dna of who we are as a
nation
is the very idea that though you may be
from somewhere else
you can find your home here
but that idea is in danger now
more than ever before
tell me when i start reading dear donald
trump
my name is estella i am 11 years old
my mom is my best friend
she came to america as a teenager over
20 years ago
without papers in search of a better
life
she married my dad who served our
country as a marine
in south america africa and iraq
my mom worked hard and paid taxes
and the obama administration told her
she could stay
my dad thought you would protect
military families
so he voted for you in 2016 mr president
he says he won't vote for you again
after what you did to our family
the wife of a u.s marine veteran was
deported to mexico
instead of protecting us you tore our
world apart my mom is a good person
and she's not a criminal
now my mom is gone and she's been taken
from us for no reason
at all every day that passes you deport
more moms and dads
and take them away from kids like me
you separated thousands of children from
their parents
and you put them in cages
some of those kids are now orphans
because of you these are people
i don't want them in our country they're
animals
mr president my mom is the wife of a
proud american marine
and a mother of two american children
we are american families we need a
president who will bring people together
not tear them apart sincerely
estella
i'm lucy sanchez and this is my mother
sylvia and sister jessica
we're like all families we work hard to
build a dead life
i was born with spina bifida that means
my spinal cord
didn't form what they should and the
doctors in my town
said i wouldn't survive they gave my
mother no hope for my future
i'm a us citizen but my mother is
undocumented
and i am a dreamer
my mother did what any mother would do
to save her baby's life
she took my sister in her arms and
traveled for days to reach the border
and when they got to the river she
lifted my sister above the water and
crossed
we came to america before i was one year
old
she saved my life
my mother had no choice there was no
time to wait to save my sister she came
here looking for a miracle
we were afraid they would find us and
detain us but she had to save her
daughter
her home is here north carolina it's all
i know
i qualified for daca but donald trump
took away my ability
to apply for the program
we work hard we contribute to our
community and we pay our taxes
i've gone to school and built a good
life for me and my two daughters
i want to go to law school i want to
help my community
but ever since donald trump was elected
all our freers have returned
we don't know if our family will be
separated will my mom and sister be
detained
will my sister get the health care she
needs and deserves i don't have the
right id
so i can't get health insurance through
the exchange
i need health insurance i deserve it
right
buena
it breaks our hearts to see children
separated from their families at the
border
that's wrong those children need their
parents on november 3rd i'm going to
vote for my mother
my sister and my daughters i will vote
for a future where all of our lives have
dignity and respect
we need a leader who will fix the broken
immigration system
and commit to keeping families together
i'm voting for joe biden in kamala
harris the daughter of immigrants
who are you going to vote for estamos
todos juntosero
trestres zero
there's something unique about america
we don't simply welcome new immigrants
we are born of immigrants that is who we
are immigration is our origin
story after all unless your
family is native america
all of our families come from someplace
else
these new americans we see our own
american stories
life in america was not always easy
there was discrimination
and hardship and poverty but like you
they no doubt
found inspiration in all those who had
come before them
and they were able to muster faith that
here in america
they might build a better life and give
their children something more
the tension throughout our history
between welcoming or rejecting the
stranger
it's about more than just immigration
it's about the meaning of america
what kind of country do we want to be
immigrants are the teachers who inspire
our children they're the doctors who
keep us healthy
they're the engineers who design our
skylines and the artists and the
entertainers who touch our hearts
immigrants are soldiers sailors airmen
marines coast guardsmen who protect us
we can never say it often or loudly
enough
immigrants and refugees revitalize and
renew america
it's not something to take for granted
something to cherish and to fight for
god bless you and god bless the united
states of america
is
just
oh
foreign
oh
stand by me
instead
me
whenever
me
stand by each other don't forget to vote
this november together we can make a
change
let's go
that was prince royce amazing shout out
to the boogie down bronx
in this next piece you'll hear about the
vital role that women have played in
moving us toward a more perfect union
and breaking through that proverbial
glass ceiling and after that
you'll hear from secretary hillary
rodham clinton the woman who put over 65
million cracks in it
a rule breaker a rabble rouser
and she is called the agitator the pushy
one
the one with attitude now is the time
for all of us to stand up and say
enough is enough
from the ballot box to the factory floor
from her living room to the er
she makes trouble the good kind
she is the mother who cries out for
sensible gun laws
the daughter who believes that equal
justice means
justice for all we are
america the child who knows that
black lives matter
she is our warrior on the front lines
challenging authority to make the world
safe
nobody is above the law
refusing to be told who makes decisions
about her body
or anyone else's these women and men of
all ages
races and backgrounds don't come to
planned parenthood
to make a political statement they come
to get quality
affordable healthcare you are
disadvantaging her because of her
sex
this is the time and she knows
that to change the world you need to
change the
idea of power excuse me mr martin this
is
my time and i control it because we are
fighting for you
each and every single day
and she knows her voice is heard and
amplified by the women she elects to
public office
if we want families to succeed
we start by empowering women when i
first got elected i came to washington
dc
to fight for the issues that are so
important in our community
we look forward to making sure that this
district is finally well represented
the things that we ran on going into
november we are doing that
women don't just fight for women they
fight for
families they fight for fairness
inclusion
justice to make our nation a more
perfect union
especially for those people who are the
most marginal
if we're going to jump start the middle
class we've got to ensure
that college is affordable separation of
families and children
are detrimental to their health give the
victims
of gender bias in the workplace the
tools they need to seek justice
women are the most important political
force in the united states of america
she represents her views on education
we've got to pay educators more
and we've got to hire more educators
we're going to raise up the profile of
teachers and celebrate who they are and
give them better pay
she represents her concerns about health
care
health care is the number one issue in
this election every day every day
she speaks out on equal pay it's very
frustrating for women everywhere
kids are feeling like they aren't
getting paid what they should be and
focuses on protecting our children let's
give parents the peace of mind
that their kids are safe and are being
set up for success
caring for our seniors and the people
who care for them
she keeps this nation going even in
challenging times
and while running for office is not easy
what's wrong with my running for
president of this country
nevertheless she persists but we learned
a long
time ago you don't get what you don't
fight for
and perseveres this is our time
and prevails although we weren't able
to shatter that highest hardest glass
ceiling this time
it's got about 18 million cracks in it
a record-breaking number of women ran in
the midterms and won
she builds coalitions and she knows who
her allies
are from the fight for health care
to authoring the violence against
women's act to building a society
where fairness and equality and
opportunity
applies to everyone joe biden knows
a stronger america is one that works
for women so go ahead and celebrate
you rebel rouser you rule breaker
you force of nature our country
our world needs you
keep rising and vote
the morning after the last election i
said
we owe donald trump an open mind and the
chance to lead
i meant it every president deserves that
and trump came in with so much set up
for him a strong economy
plans for managing crises including a
pandemic
yes we democrats would have disagreed
with him on many things
but if he had put his own interests and
ego aside
seeing the humanity in a child ripped
from her parents at the border
or a protester calling for justice or a
family wiped out by natural disaster
that would have been a good thing for
america and the world
i wish donald trump knew how to be a
president
because america needs a president
right now throughout this time of crisis
americans keep going
checking on neighbors showing up to jobs
as first responders
hospitals grocery stores nursing homes
yes it still takes a village and we need
leaders equal to this moment of
sacrifice
and service we need joe biden
and kamala harris everyone has a story
about
joe's caring and empathy i remember him
calling after my mother dorothy died and
we talked about
being raised by strong women the best
testament to joe
is how he's cared for his family and how
great is it
that dr jill biden plans to keep
teaching as first lady
and joe picked the right partner in
kamala she's relentless in the pursuit
of justice and equity
and she's kind when her press secretary
tyrone gail was dying of cancer
she dropped everything to be with him in
his final moments
i know something about the slings and
arrows she'll face and believe me
this former district attorney and
attorney general can handle them
all so this is the team
to pull our nation back from the brink
but they can't do it without us
for four years people have told me
i didn't realize how dangerous he was i
wish i could do it all over
or worse i should have voted
look this can't be another woulda coulda
shoulda
election if you vote by mail request
your ballot now
and send it back right away if you vote
in person do it early
become a poll worker most of all no
matter what
vote as michelle obama and bernie
sanders warned us
if trump is re-elected things will get
even worse
that's why we need unity now more than
ever
remember back in 2016 when trump asked
what do you have to lose
well now we know our health care our
jobs
our loved ones our leadership in the
world and
even our post office but let's set our
sights higher than getting one man out
of the white house
joe biden and kamala harris are going to
give us
so much to vote for let's vote for the
jobs that
joe's plan will create clean energy jobs
to fight climate change caregiving jobs
with living wages
vote for emergency relief that lifts
small businesses
and saves hard-working people from
foreclosures
and evictions it's wrong that
billionaires got 400
billion dollars richer during the
pandemic while millions
lost their 600 dollar a week in extra
unemployment
vote for the parents and teachers
struggling to balance children's
education
and safety and for health care workers
fighting
covet 19 with little help from the white
house
vote for paid family leave and health
care for everyone
for social security medicare and planned
parenthood
vote for dreamers and their families
vote for law enforcement
purged a racial bias that keeps all our
streets safe
vote for justice for george floyd
brianna taylor and ahmad arberi
because black lives matter vote for
honest elections
so we not a foreign adversary choose
our president vote for the diverse
hopeful america we saw in last night's
roll call and don't forget
joe and kamala can win by 3 million
votes
and still lose take it from me
so we need numbers overwhelming so trump
can't sneak
or steal his way to victory text
vote 30330 to get started
a hundred years ago yesterday the 19th
amendment to the constitution was
ratified
it took seven decades of suffragists
marching
picketing and going to jail to push us
closer to a more perfect union 55 years
ago
john lewis marched and bled in selma
because that work was
unfinished tonight i'm thinking of the
girls and boys who see themselves
in america's future because of kamala
harris
a black woman the daughter of jamaican
and indian immigrants and
our nominee for vice president
this is our country's story breaking
down barriers and expanding the circle
of possibility and to the young people
watching
don't give up on america despite our
flaws and problems we've come
so far we can still be a more just
equal country with opportunities
previous generations could never have
imagined there's a lot of heartbreak in
america now
and the truth is many things were broken
before the pandemic
but as the saying goes the world breaks
everyone and afterward many are strong
at the broken places
that's joe biden he knows how to keep
going
unify and lead because he's done that
for his family and country
so come november if we're strong
together
we'll heal together we'll redeem the
soul and the promise
of our country led by president
joe biden and vice president kamala
harris
tonight is a night steeped in women who
have stepped into service
and advocacy and who are using their
power for good
the power of women is undeniable whether
it's in the office
in the home or in the house of
representatives
it is my honor to introduce the speaker
of the house
nancy pelosi
i was never raised in a way that i would
be running for public office it didn't
interest me
when i graduated from college i got
married had five children in six years
so that was my life when the children
were grown
the opportunity to run for congress came
along she ran
because another woman said run and she
won
starting on a path that would make
history the
first woman speaker of the house
for our daughters and our granddaughters
today we have
broken the marble ceiling
in her so many saw themselves
i did feel a real responsibility to
other women
as i stood on the shoulders of those who
went before
now it was her turn to say run
and run they did winning and
making her speaker once again
we didn't have a speaker who would bring
a gun bill to the floor we didn't have a
speaker who would bring a dreamer's
issue to the floor
we do now and that's good for every
american
but not everyone was on board nancy
pelosi pelosi pelosi
i'm a mother of five grandmothers nine i
know a temper tantrum when i say
the power of the speaker is awesome
awesome
if you want to go into the arena you
have to be prepared
to take a punch you also have to be
prepared
to throw a punch for the children
throw a punch
from running the house to speaker of the
house
and taking on the white house
unapologetic
unafraid madam speaker deliciously
and now please welcome speaker of the
united states house of representatives
my honor to everybody
the greetings of house democrats the
most diverse
majority in history more than 60 percent
women
people of color and lgbtq our diversity
is our strength
our unity is our power this month
as america marks the centennial of women
finally women
winning the right to vote we do so with
105 women
in the house proudly 90
are democrats to win the vote women
marched and fought never gave in
we stand on their shoulders charged with
carrying forward the unfinished work of
our nation
advanced by heroes from seneca falls to
selma to stonewall
four years ago when president obama and
vice president biden were in the white
house
they made us proud and their leadership
made our country great
in that spirit we come together now not
to
decry the darkness but to light a way
forward
for our country that is the guiding
purpose of house democrats
fighting for the people we have sent the
senate bills for lower health care costs
for bigger paychecks
for cleaner government protecting john
lewis's voting rights
and enacting george floyd justice and
policing act
we sent the senate bills to protect our
dreamers lgbtq equality to prevent gun
violence
and to preserve our planet for future
generations
and even more all of this is possible
for america
who was standing in the way mitch
mcconnell
and donald trump our nation
faces the worst health and economic
catastrophe in our history
more than 5 million americans are
infected by the coronavirus
over 170 thousand have died
the science-based action in the heroes
act we enacted three months ago
is essential to safeguard lives
livelihood
and the life of our democracy and who is
standing in the way
mitch mcconnell and donald trump instead
of crushing the virus
they're trying to crush the affordable
care act it's pre-and
pre-existing conditions benefit
as speaker of the house i've been i've
seen firsthand donald trump's disrespect
for facts
for working families and for women in
particular
disrespect written into his policies
toward our health and our rights
not just his conduct but we know what he
doesn't
that when women succeed america succeeds
and so we are unleashing the power of
women to take our rightful place
in our national life by championing a
woman's right to choose and defending
roe v
wade securing safe and affordable child
care
preserving social security and passing
equal pay
for equal work who's standing in the way
mitch mcconnell and donald trump so here
is our answer
we will remember in november when we
will elect joe biden president
whose heart is full of love for america
and rid the country of trump's heartless
disregard
for america's goodness joe biden's faith
in god gives him the courage to lead
jill biden's love gives him the strength
to persevere
joe biden is the president we need right
now battle tested forward-looking honest
and authentic
he has never forgotten who he is
fighting for
and kamala harris is the vice president
we need right now
committed to our constitution brilliant
in defending it
and a witness to the women of this
nation that our voices
will be heard our mission is to fight
for a future equal to the ideals of our
founders
our hopes for our children and the
sacrifices of our veterans
our brave men and women in uniform and
their families
we'll increase our majority in the house
we will win a democratic majority in the
senate
we will elect kamala harris vice
president and we will elect
joe biden president of the united states
of america
god bless you and god bless america
thank you speaker pelosi the house is
the people's house
and to ensure it stays that way we need
everyone to help fund our work to elect
joe biden and democrats up and down the
ballot
if you are able please go to
joebiden.com now and chip in
whatever you can to support this
campaign
last year under speaker pelosi's
leadership the house reauthorized
the violence against women act joe biden
wrote that landmark law nearly 30 years
ago
since then he and other leaders have
built on it
but for all of this work women are still
not entirely safe so the work
must continue joe biden knows that
and he is committed to doing that work
to making sure that women are
safe and to making sure our voices are
heard
let's listen
my name is ruth glenn in 1992 my husband
shot me and left me for dead
for 13 years my son and i had been
abused by him
we finally escaped but he tracked us
down
back then there was limited help
available and no national hotline to
call
local shelters were full i didn't even
know the name for what was happening to
me then
domestic violence now working to end
domestic violence is my life's work
i'm marisha hargitay when i started
doing research to play detective olivia
benson on law
order svu over 20 years ago i was
shocked
to find out how many people including
children
experience physical or sexual abuse
the statistics fueled my resolve and i
committed myself to the movement
to end this violence my name is carly
dryden
in my small hometown i didn't feel like
i could speak out about my experience
with sexual assault
but at the university of puget sound i
met an incredible force of people
working to end the culture of sexual
assault i went from survivor
to advocate as the president
and ceo of the national coalition
against domestic violence
i've seen joe biden's passionate
leadership in passing the violence
against women act
now domestic violence rates are rising
due to this pandemic
we need congress to reauthorize and
enhance that law
we need leaders who believe that a
woman's life is worth
fighting for joe biden is that kind of
leader
i created the joyful heart foundation to
help survivors heal
and to change the way our society
responds to sexual violence
the vice president has worked tirelessly
by our side
to end the backlog of hundreds of
thousands
of untested rape kits and our work will
continue
because testing kids not only makes our
country safer
but it sends a vital message to
survivors
that what happened to them matters
the most important thing you can say to
a survivor is i hear you
that's why i became a leader and it's on
us
it's a program started by vice president
biden to eliminate
sexual assault on college campuses and
support a new generation of advocates
including men and boys because if you're
silent
you're complicit and we're just getting
started
i am voting for jill biden on behalf of
all victims and survivors of domestic
violence
i'm voting for joe biden because it's on
my generation to make sure that we never
go back
i'm voting for joe biden for my daughter
for my sons for all
of our children
first episode was a flap to the face and
he broke my eardrum
punching kicking choking threatening
with an eye for a gun
he had always threatened me if i had
ever called the police on him that he
would kill me
you didn't hear voices like these in the
halls of the u.s
capitol my husband stabbed me 13 times
and broke my neck while the police were
on the scene i nearly died and i am
permanently paralyzed
senator joe biden invited them to speak
battered women need to be taken
seriously proper police response
can prevent what happened to me from
happening to someone else
thank you thank you
at the time the police considered
domestic violence something
that was not a crime in the home it's a
private matter
and so women were responsible for their
own injuries
i was about to say no i don't know
i can only guess how uh
how uh how painful that is
growing up our father said that the
greatest of all sins
was the abuse of power he
told us when a bully when someone bigger
or stronger takes advantage of you
that is a really grave sin
the expectation was for all four of us
be a person of character
you see something wrong we were then
expected to stand up
and do something about it
when joe introduced the legislation few
believed it to pass
our bill is an ambitious undertaking it
is a first attempt to address
violent crimes against women it was hard
to get the votes
because you had some traditionalists who
just didn't believe that there should be
laws about this
but joe doesn't give up he's tenacious
joe persevered and he's very good at
persuasion
they're doing he brought together law
enforcement
prosecutors advocates and survivors
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to come and speak
in 1994 the violence against women act
became
law and protected millions of american
women
a lot of the change in the attitudes we
have about domestic violence
were shaped by his leadership on this
if you see something wrong we were then
expected to stand up
and do something about it
if you're just joining us welcome coming
up we're going to hear from president
barack obama
and senator kamala harris who will talk
about the biden
harris vision for the future but in
order to get to that more perfect union
we have to acknowledge where we are
today
in america we are struggling
unemployment has skyrocketed and
families are fighting to keep their jobs
as joe biden says we need to build back
better
to find out how you can join that effort
please
text join to 30330 to get plugged into
this campaign
and to get more information on how to
vote and how to volunteer
joe biden has a plan to help working
families and small businesses
our next speaker hilda solis worked
alongside him as secretary of labor
to make sure that there were good
american jobs and that americans were
safe on the job to hear more about the
biden harris economic plan
please welcome gilda solis
hello i'm hilda solis the day vice
president biden swarming in as secretary
of labor
was one of the proudest moments of my
life
my parents realized they had achieved
their american dream
because the daughter of two blue-collar
immigrants
would make history and give voice to
people just like them
american workers need a fighter now more
than
ever and joe biden is that person
because he has done it before and i've
seen it firsthand
he and president obama made it easier
for home care workers to
organize they extended overtime pay
to more than 4 million workers they
saved the automobile industry and a
whole lot of good
union jobs with it and when millions of
families lost their homes
my friend from california senator kamala
harris
took on the big banks and won but
because of donald trump's failures
we must once again rescue a sinking
economy
millions of americans are out of work
and communities of color
are the hardest hit millions of
essential workers are putting their
lives at risk
with little protections and millions
more are just
plain tired that's why joe biden
and kamala harris actually have a plan
not only to recover what we lost but to
improve upon it
to build back better creating
5 million good union jobs by bringing
back supply chains
to america that's building back better
creating millions of jobs by investing
in clean
energy that's building back better and
making sure that working families
can afford child care that's how we
build back better
so let me borrow and slightly edit
something joe biden said
at my swearing-in when it comes to
expanding the economy
for all people no one no one is going to
be a stronger voice
than our next president joe biden
the conversation you're about to see
proves it
behind every business there's a story
small businesses around the country are
bearing the economic
brunt of the coronavirus pandemic and
behind every business there's a family
a lot of people clearly are in pain
right now
for every farm there's a fight to stay
whole there's hard work
and there's heartbreak we are going to
lose 20 to 30 percent of our small
businesses
this is the story of kevin and molly
johnson
family-owned business in lake county
ohio
we have 10 to 12 employees on a
given day when kova 19 hit
it was a lot of confusion i remember
being scared and being uncertain we shut
down last week
because we ran out of work and we got
enough to come in for another week
if we don't get additional orders in
we're going to have to look at another
shutdown
you can't make a big purchase equipment
you can't plan for this we don't even
know if we can cover payroll
when this isn't going well it's it's
scary
you're kind of forgotten right the
president always bragging about the
stock market
sort of leaves leaves a lot of small
manufacturing companies behind
we could use a little help right now and
it just seems like we get one step
forward and then
two steps back
this is the story of jere green who just
started a clothing store
and then covet hit fashion has been
a love of mine for oh since i was a kid
i worked really hard to save money
to open this door did my ribbon cutting
december 14
of 2019 and you know it was booming and
then bam
here's kovit it was scary no one was
buying anything
my employees they're gone i reached out
to
my bank but they stated that they had no
more money it's gone to
a lot of the bigger businesses the
million dollar businesses who
get the bail out and a small business
like myself is just that
to struggle being an african-american
female
business owner under president trump i
feel how can i say
i'm alone i'm alone
this is the story of lin taw and her two
restaurants
one closed and one still
open it's always really hard for
restaurants to
begin it would be crowded in here with
babies and families and crowds outside
waiting to get in it was pretty exciting
and on the day of the shutdown we were
actually reviewed in the los angeles
times on that day
the virus was announced as a global
pandemic it's really really sad to see
and if we don't turn this around soon i
mean we're going to see this not just be
this year but you're gonna see ghost
town for
main street usa the first decision that
i had to make because
100 people are looking at you and
unfortunately the call
was to furlough everybody at this point
i don't even see myself
we don't ask for much from government
but catch us when we're falling
and i know that it must feel like you're
falling right now without a net
restaurants are among the hardest
businesses
to succeed at but i was going to do it
in a way that was going to
provide a successful career for not only
myself but 100 employees
this is the story of dan reiner he's a
fifth generation farmer
struggling to keep his business alive
i'm not so sure that president
understands that when he thinks about
business i don't think he thinks about
farmers
no as a business no he has no clue about
this stuff
dan tell me a little bit about the farm
we've been here since 1864.
trade tariffs with china have just been
horrible part of the language in the
trade deal
said that china does not have to buy
unless the price is to their advantage
what kind of trade deal is that
that's no deal then when coveted hit
then everything just plummeted
getting through now that's the problem
that's the day-to-day
battle i believe that joe biden will be
a clear voice for us something that we
have not had
joe biden has an understanding of what
the average american
is experiencing i think he's with me
enough is enough it's time to help small
businesses
middle-class folks manage their way
through a pandemic i have a lot of
confidence in joe biden
he's a fighter and he's the real deal
we've taken a lot of
knockdowns and we know that at the end
of the day we will endure
we will rise again every time i get
knocked down i gotta get up and keep
running
keep going keep going
tonight we've heard from the people who
make america work
people who put their lives on the line
to keep our country going and
since covid 19 hit they've taken one
gut punch after another and what is the
coveted fallout done to our babies
well i'm here at the early childhood
education center in springfield
massachusetts
which has been closed for months child
care was already hard to find before the
pandemic and now
parents are stuck no idea when schools
can safely reopen and even
fewer child care options the devastation
is enormous
and the way i see it big problems demand
big solutions now i love a good plan
and joe biden has some really good plans
plans to bring back
union jobs in manufacturing and create
new union jobs in clean energy
plans to increase social security
benefits cancel
billions in student loan debt and make
our bankruptcy laws work for
families instead of the creditors who
cheat them
these plans reflect a central truth our
economic system has been rigged to give
bailouts to billionaires and kick dirt
in the face of
everyone else but we can build a
thriving economy by investing in
families and fixing what's broken
joe's plan to build back better includes
making the wealthy pay
their fair share holding corporations
accountable
repairing racial inequities and fighting
corruption
in washington let me tell you about one
of joe's plans
that's especially close to my heart
child care
as a little girl growing up in oklahoma
what i wanted
most in the world was to be a teacher i
loved teaching and when i had babies and
was juggling my first big teaching job
down in texas
it was hard but i could do hard
the thing that almost sank me child care
one night my aunt b called just to check
in
and i thought i was fine but then
i just broke down and started to cry i
had tried holding it all together but
without reliable
child care working was nearly impossible
and when i told aunt b i was going to
quit my job
i thought my heart would break and then
she said the words that changed my life
i can't get there tomorrow
but i'll come on thursday and she
arrived with seven suitcases and a
pekingese named buddy
and stayed for 16 years
i get to be here tonight because of my
aunt b
i learned a fundamental truth nobody
makes it on their own
and yet here we are two generations of
working parents later
and if you have a baby and don't have an
aunt bee
you're on your own and here's why that
is wrong
we build infrastructure like roads and
bridges and communication
systems so that people can work that
infrastructure helps us all because it
keeps our economy
going it's time to recognize that child
care is part of the basic
infrastructure of this nation it's
infrastructure
for families joe and kamala will make
high quality child care affordable for
every family
make preschool universal and raise the
wages of
every child care worker now that's just
one plan but it gives you an idea of how
we get this country working
for everyone donald trump's
ignorance and incompetence have always
been a danger to our country
coveted 19 was trump's biggest test
he failed miserably
today america has the most coveted
deaths in the world
and an economic collapse and both
crises are falling hardest on black and
brown
families millions out of work millions
more trapped in cycles of poverty
millions on the brink of losing their
homes millions of restaurants and stores
hanging by a thread this crisis is bad
and it didn't have to be this way
this crisis is on donald trump
and the republicans who enable him on
november 3rd
we will hold them all accountable
so whether you're planning to vote
wearing a mask or vote by mail please
take out your phone right now and text
vote to three zero three
three zero we all need to be in the
fight to get joe and kamala elected
and after november we all need to stay
in the fight
to get big things done
we stay in this fight so that when our
children
and our grandchildren ask what we did
during this dark chapter in our nation's
history
we will be able to look them squarely in
the eye and say
we organized we persisted
and we changed america
former president barack obama has said
that choosing joe biden to be his vice
president
was one of the best decisions he ever
made and this is a man
who has made a lot of good decisions
making health care more affordable and
accessible rescuing our economy
protecting american jobs
marrying michelle obama and through it
all
joe biden was by his side except for
maybe marrying michelle
you can witness their mutual respect and
affection
in this clip take a look
joe for your faith in your fellow
americans
for your love of country and for your
lifetime of service
that will endure through the generations
i'd like to
ask the military aide to join us on
stage
for the final time as president
i am pleased to award our nation's
highest civilian honor
the presidential medal of freedom
man
and for
for the first for the first and only
time in my presidency i will bestow this
medal with an additional
level of veneration on honor my three
most recent successors
reserved for only three others pope john
paul ii
president ronald reagan and general
colin powell
ladies and gentlemen i am proud to award
the presidential medal of freedom with
distinction
to my brother joseph robinette
biden jr will the aide please read the
citation
vice president joseph r biden jr
in a career of public service spanning
nearly half a century
vice president joseph r biden jr has
left his mark on almost every part of
our nation
fighting for a stronger middle class a
fairer judicial
system and a smarter foreign policy
providing unyielding support for our
troops combating crime and violence
against women
leading our quest to cure cancer and
safeguarding the landmark
american recovery and reinvestment act
from corruption
with his charm candor unabashed optimism
and deep and abiding patriotism joe
biden has garnered the respect and
esteem of colleagues
of both parties and the friendship of
people across the nation
and around the world while summoning the
strength
faith and grace to overcome great
personal tragedy
this son of scranton claymont and
wilmington
has become one of the most consequential
vice presidents in american history
an accolade that nonetheless rests
firmly behind his legacy
as husband father and grandfather
a grateful nation thanks vice president
joseph r biden jr
for his lifetime of service on behalf of
the united states of america
okay
good evening everybody as you've seen by
now this
isn't a normal convention it's not a
normal time
so tonight i want to talk as plainly as
i can
about the stakes in this election
because what we do these next 76 days
will echo through generations to come
i'm in philadelphia where our
constitution was drafted
and signed it wasn't a perfect document
it allowed for the inhumanity of slavery
and failed to guarantee women and even
men who didn't own property
the right to participate in the
political process
but embedded in this document was a
north star that would guide future
generations
a system of representative government a
democracy
through which we could better realize
our highest ideals
through civil war and bitter struggles
we improved this constitution to include
the voices of those
who'd once been left out and gradually
we made this country
more just and more equal
and more free the one
constitutional office elected by all of
the people
is the presidency so to minimum we
should expect a president
to feel a sense of responsibility for
the safety and welfare
of all 330 million of us
regardless of what we look like how we
worship who we love
how much money we have or who we voted
for
but we should also expect a president to
be the custodian of this democracy
we should expect that regardless of ego
ambition
or political beliefs the president will
preserve
protect and defend the freedoms and
ideals that
so many americans marched for went to
jail for
fought for and died for
i have sat in the oval office with both
of the men who are running for president
i never expected that my successor would
embrace my vision
or continue my policies
i did hope for the sake of our country
that donald trump might show some
interest
in taking the job seriously
that he might come to feel the weight of
the office
and discover some reverence for the
democracy
that had been placed in his care
but he never did
for close to four years now he has shown
no
interest in putting in the work no
interest in finding common ground
no interest in using the awesome power
of his office to help anyone but
himself and his friends
no interest in treating the presidency
as anything but one more reality show
that he can use
to get the attention he craves
donald trump hasn't grown into the job
because he can't
and the consequences of that failure are
severe
170 000 americans dead
millions of jobs gone well those at the
top taken more than ever
our worst impulses unleashed
our proud reputation around the world
badly diminished
and our democratic institutions
threatened like never before
now i know that in times as polarized as
these
most of you have already made up your
mind
but maybe you're still not sure which
candidate you'll vote for
or whether you'll vote at all
maybe you're tired of the direction
we're headed but you can't
see a better path yet or you just don't
know enough about the person
who wants to lead us there
so let me tell you about my friend joe
biden
12 years ago when i began my search for
a vice president
i didn't know i'd end up finding a
brother
joe and i come from different places
different generations but
what i quickly came to admire about
joe biden is his resilience born of too
much struggle
his empathy born of too much grief
joe is a man who learned early on to
treat
every person he meets with respect and
dignity
living by the words his parents taught
him no one's better than you joe
but you're better than nobody
that empathy that decency
the belief that everybody counts
that's who joe is
when he talks with someone who's lost
her job joel remembers the night his
father sat him down to say
that he'd lost his
when joe listens to a parent who's
trying to hold it
all together right now he does it
as a single dad who took the train back
to
wilmington each and every night so he
could tuck his kids into bed
when he meets with military families
who've lost their hero
he does it as a kindred spirit the
parent
of an american soldier somebody whose
faith has endured
the hardest loss there is
for eight years joe was the last one in
the room whenever
i faced a big decision he made me a
better president
and he's got the character and the
experience to make us
a better country and then my friend
kamala harris he's chosen an ideal
partner
who is more than prepared for the job
someone who knows what it's like to
overcome barriers and who's made a
career
fighting to help others live out their
own american dream
along with the experience needed to get
things done joe and kamala
have concrete policies that will turn
their vision of a better fairer stronger
country
into reality they will get this pandemic
under control
like joe did when he helped me manage
h1n1
and prevent an ebola outbreak from
reaching our shores
they'll expand health care to more
americans like joe and i did 10 years
ago
when he helped craft the affordable care
act and nail down the votes to make it
the law
they'll rescue the economy like joe
helped me do after the great recession
i asked him to manage the recovery act
which jump-started the longest stretch
of job growth in history
and he sees this moment now not as a
chance to get back to where we were
but to make long overdue changes so that
our economy actually makes life a little
easier
for everybody whether it's the waitress
trying to
raise a kid on her own or the shift
worker
always on the edge of getting laid off
for the student
figuring out how to pay for next
semester's classes
joe and kamala will restore our standing
in the world and as we've learned from
this pandemic
that matters joe knows the world
and the world knows him
he knows that our true strength comes
from setting an example
that the world wants to follow a nation
that stands with democracy
not dictators a nation that can inspire
and mobilize others to overcome threats
like climate change and terrorism
poverty and disease
but more than anything what i know
about joe what i know about kamala
is that they actually care about every
american
and that they care deeply about this
democracy
they believe that in a democracy
the right to vote is sacred and we
should be making it easier for people to
cast their ballots
not harder
they believe that no one including the
president
is above the law and that no public
official including the president should
use their office
to enrich themselves or their supporters
they understand that in this democracy
the commander-in-chief
does not use the men and women of our
military who are willing to risk
everything to protect our nation as
political props
to deploy against peaceful protesters on
our own soil
they understand that political opponents
aren't un-american just because they
disagree with you
a free press isn't the enemy but the way
we
hold officials accountable that our
ability to work together to solve big
problems like a pandemic
depend on a fidelity to facts and
science
and logic and not just making stuff up
none of this should be controversial
these shouldn't be republican principles
or democratic principles they are
american principles
but at this moment this president
and those who enable him have shown
they don't believe in these things
tonight i'm asking you to believe in joe
and kamala's ability to lead this
country out of these dark times and
build it back better
but here's the thing no single american
can fix this country alone not even a
president
democracy was never meant to be
transactional you give me your vote i
make everything better
it requires an active and informed
citizenry
so i'm also asking you to believe in
your own ability
to embrace your own responsibility as
citizens
to make sure that the basic tenets of
our democracy endure
because that's what's at stake right now
our democracy
look i understand why
a lot of americans are down on
government the way the rules have been
set up
and abused in congress make it easier
for special interests to stop progress
than to make progress
believe me i i know it i understand why
a
white factory worker who's seen his
wages cut or his job shipped overseas
might
feel like the government no longer looks
out for him
and why a black mom might feel like it
never looked out for her at all
i understand why a new immigrant might
look around this country and wonder
whether there's still a place for him
here
why a young person might look at
politics right now
the circus of it all the meanness and
the lies
and conspiracy theories and think
what is the point
well here's the point this president
and those in power those who benefit
from keeping things
the way they are they are counting on
your cynicism
they know they can't win you over with
their policies
so they're hoping to make it as hard as
possible
for you to vote and to convince you that
your vote does not matter
that is how they win that is how they
get to keep making decisions that affect
your life
and the lives of the people you love
that's how the economy will keep getting
skewed to the wealthy and well connected
how our health systems will let more
people fall through the cracks
that's how a democracy withers until
it's no democracy at all
and we cannot let that happen
do not let them take away your power
do not let them take away your democracy
make a plan right now for how you are
going to get involved and vote
but as early as you can and tell your
family and friends how they can vote too
do what americans have done for over two
centuries when faced
with even tougher times than this
all those quiet heroes who found the
courage to keep marshy
keep pushing in the face of hardship and
injustice
last month we lost a giant of american
democracy
in john lewis and some years ago i sat
down with john
and a few remaining leaders of
the early civil rights movement
one of them told me he never imagined
he'd walk into the white house
and see a president who looked like his
grandson
and then he told me that he had looked
it up
and it turned out that on the very day
that i was born
he was marching into a jail cell
trying to end jim crow segregation in
the south
what we do echoes
through generations
whatever our backgrounds we are all the
children of americans who fought the
good fight
great-grandparents working in fire traps
and sweatshops without rights
or representation farmers
losing their dreams to dust
irish and italians and asians and
latinos told
go back where you come from
jews and catholics muslims and sikhs
made to feel suspect for the way they
worshipped
black americans chained and whipped
and hanged spit on
for trying to sit at lunch counters
be for trying to vote
if anyone had a right to believe that
this democracy did not work
and could not work it was those
americans
our ancestors they were on
the receiving end of a democracy that
had fallen short all their lives
they knew how far the daily reality of
america strayed from the men
and yet instead of giving up they joined
together
and they said somehow some way we are
going to make this work
we are going to bring those words
in our founding documents to life
i have seen that same spirit rising
these past few years
folks of every age and background who
packed city centers and airports and
rural roads so that families wouldn't be
separated
so that another classroom wouldn't get
shot up
so that our kids won't grow up on an
uninhabitable planet
americans of all races joining together
to declare
in the face of injustice
and brutality at the hands of the state
that black lives matter no more
but no less so that no child in this
country
feels the continuing sting of racism
to the young people who led us this
summer telling us
we need to be better
in so many ways you are this country's
dreams fulfilled
earlier generations had to be persuaded
that everyone
has equal worth for you it's a given
a conviction
and what i want you to know is that for
all its messiness and frustrations
your system of self-government
can be harnessed to help you realize
those convictions for all of us
you can give our democracy new meaning
you can take it to a better place
you're the missing ingredient the ones
who will decide whether or not america
becomes the country that fully
lives up to its creed
that work will continue long after this
election
but any chance of success depends
entirely
on the outcome of this election
this administration has shown it will
tear our democracy
down if that's what it takes for them to
win
so we have to get busy building it up
by pouring all our efforts into these 76
days
and by voting like never before for joe
and kamala
and candidates up and down the ticket
so that we leave no doubt about
what this country that we love
stands for today
and for all our days to come
stay safe god bless
thank you president obama for your thank
you for your brilliant leadership
joe biden has chosen an extraordinary
woman
to be his running mate kamala harris is
a fighter
and a trailblazer using her
groundbreaking ideas to protect families
and
keep them together by reducing
recidivism
i am so thrilled for her to become
the vice president of the united states
now please welcome our convention chair
congressman benny thompson
delegates and distinguished guests our
procedural rules provide
that the presidential candidate who
obtained a majority of all
pledged and automatic delegates will
nominate the democratic candidate
for vice president in accordance with
our rules
vice president biden has nominated
senator kamala harris
as his vice presidential candidate our
rules further provide
that if only one candidate is nominated
for vice president
the chair is authorized to declare the
nominee the democratic candidate
for vice president as such with only one
nomination received
and pursuant to our rules i hereby
declare
that kamala harris is elected as the
democratic candidate
for vice president
i'm pleased to report that vice
presidential candidate kamala harris
has been invited to deliver an
acceptance speech
kamala harris is my auntie my stepmom
my big sister which means you'll always
be my older sister
and there are some things we'd like to
share with you to my brother and me
you'll always be mama
the world's greatest stepmom you're my
role model
who taught me i could do and be anything
i wanted
my very first friend my confidant my
partner
in mischief and injustice you're a rock
not just for our dad but for three
generations of our big blended family
you showed me the importance of public
service
and made sure i grew up surrounded by
smart strong
ambitious women every day growing up
having helped the poor kid who picked on
me because my big sister would be there
in a flash ready to have my back
well now we've got your back as you and
joe
fight to protect our democracy and
there's no union more perfect than the
one that brings us
all to your kitchen table every sunday
night for stir fry
feta chicken or spaghetti and meatball
family dinners
and now that i'm a mom you're showing my
daughters and so many girls
around the world who look like them
what's possible
and what it's like to move through the
world as fierce
formidable phenomenal women in their own
unique way i love you i admire you
i am so proud of you and even though
mommy's not here to see her first
daughter step into history
the entire nation will see in your
strength
your integrity your intelligence and
your optimism
the values that she raised us with we
love you mama
we're so proud of you auntie
you mean the world to us kamala and we
could not be
more excited to share you with the world
as the next
as the next vice president vice
president of the united states
joe biden has selected kamala harris as
his running mate she is the first black
woman first south asian woman
to be named on the democratic team
someone who looks like us on a
presidential ticket that's
crazy kamala harris is us
she was born in oakland the daughter of
immigrants
the daughter of chandler
big sister and protector she
is an hvcu brand
she is a woman of many firsts
she's a hard worker a really hard worker
she's brilliant she's smart she's tough
and just got a big future
she's probably one of the best role
models
come on harris is like it drinked me
senator harris cares
about people there's no doubt about it
she fights for women's rights she fights
to end mass incarceration
she is a fearless advocate for the voice
the litmus test for america
is how we are treating black women now
i'm talking about someone who can fight
for black people
brown people undocumented people lgbt
people disabled people young people old
people
all of america it's about all of us
knowing our power
teaches us to lift people up right
and to remind them that we see them and
we hear them and that they matter
are you going to be vice president of
the united states
greetings america it is
truly an honor to be speaking with you
tonight
that i am here tonight is a testament to
the dedication of generations before me
women and men who believed so fiercely
in the promise of equality liberty
and justice for all this week marks the
100th anniversary of the passage of the
19th amendment
and we celebrate the women who fought
for that right
yet so many of the black women who
helped secure that victory
were still prohibited from voting long
after
its ratification but they were
undeterred
without fanfare or recognition they
organized and testified and rallied and
marched and
fought not just for their vote but for a
seat at the table
these women and the generations that
followed
worked to make democracy and
opportunity real in the lives of all of
us
who followed they paved the way
for the trail blazing leadership of
barack obama
and hillary clinton and these women
inspired us to pick up the torch
and fight on women like mary church
tyrell
mary cloyd bethune fannie lou hamer
and diane nash constance baker
motley and the great shirley chisholm
we're not often taught their stories
but as americans we all stand on their
shoulders
and there's another woman whose name
isn't known
whose story isn't shared another woman
whose shoulders i stand on and that's my
mother
shamala gopalan harris
she came here from india at age 19 to
pursue
her dream of curing cancer at the
university of california berkeley she
met my father donald harris
who had come from jamaica to study
economics
they fell in love in that most american
way
while marching together for justice in
the civil rights movement of the 1960s
in the streets of oakland and berkeley
i got a stroller's eye view of people
getting into what the great
john lewis called good trouble
when i was five my parents split and my
mother raised us mostly on her own
like so many mothers she worked around
the clock
to make it work packing lunches before
we woke up
and paying bills after we went to bed
helping us with homework at the kitchen
table and shuttling us to church for
choir practice
she made it look easy though it never
was
my mother instilled in my sister maya
and me the values that we chart
the course of our lives she raised us
to be proud strong black women
and she raised us to know and be proud
of our indian heritage she taught us
to put family first the family you're
born
into and the family you choose
family is my husband doug
who i met on a blind date set up by my
best friend
family is our beautiful children cole
and ella
who call me mamala family
is my sister family is my best
friend my nieces and my god children
family is my uncles my aunts and my
chitties
family is mrs shelton my second mother
who lived two doors down and helped
raise me
family is my beloved alpha kappa alpha
our divine nine and my hbcu
brothers and sisters family
is the friends i turn to when my mother
the most important person in my life
passed away
from cancer and even as she taught us
to keep our family at the center of our
world
she also pushed us to see a world
beyond ourselves she taught
us to be conscious and compassionate
about the struggles of all people to
believe
public service is a noble cause and the
fight for justice
is a shared responsibility
that led me to become a lawyer
a district attorney attorney general
and a united states senator and at
every step of the way i've been guided
by the words i spoke from the first time
i
stood in a courtroom kamala harris
for the people i have fought for
children
and survivors of sexual assault i fought
against transnational criminal
organizations
i took on the biggest banks and helped
take down one of the biggest
for-profit colleges
i know a predator when i see one
my mother taught me that service to
others
gives life purpose and meaning
and oh how i wish she were here tonight
but i know she's looking down on me from
above
i keep thinking about that 25 year old
indian woman
all of five feet tall who gave birth to
me
at kaiser hospital in oakland california
on that day she probably could have
never imagined
that i would be standing before you now
and speaking
these words i accept
your nomination for vice president of
the united states of america
i do so committed to the values
she taught me to the word
that teaches me to walk by faith
and not by sight
and to a vision passed on through
generations of americans
one that joe biden shares
a vision of our nation as a beloved
community
where all are welcome no matter what we
look like
no matter where we come from or who we
love
a country where we may not agree on
every detail
but we are united by the fundamental
belief
that every human being is of infinite
worth
deserving of compassion dignity
and respect a country
where we look out for one another where
we rise
and fall as one where we
face our challenges and celebrate our
triumphs
together
today that country feels distant
donald trump's failure of leadership has
cost
lives and livelihoods
if you're a parent struggling with your
child's remote learning
or you're a teacher struggling on the
other side of that screen
you know what we're doing right now is
not working
and we are a nation
that is grieving grieving the loss of
life
the loss of jobs the loss of
opportunities the loss of
normalcy and yes the loss
of certainty and while
this virus touches us all
we got to be honest it is not an equal
opportunity offender black
latino and indigenous people are
suffering and dying disproportionately
and this is not a coincidence it is the
effect
of structural racism of inequities in
education and technology
health care and housing job security and
transportation
the injustice in reproductive and
maternal health care
in the excessive use of force by police
and in our broader criminal justice
system
this virus it has no eyes
and yet it knows exactly how we
see each other and how we treat
each other and let's be clear
there is no vaccine for racism
we've got to do the work
for george floyd for brianna taylor
for the lives of too many others to name
for our children and for
all of us we've got to do the work
to fulfill that promise of equal justice
under law because here's the thing
none of us are free until all of us
are free so we're at an inflection point
the constant chaos leaves us adrift
the incompetence makes us feel afraid
the callousness makes us feel alone
it's a lot and here's the thing
we can do better and deserve
so much more we
must elect a president who will bring
something different
something better and do the important
work a president who will
bring all of us together black
white latino asian indigenous
to achieve the future we collectively
want
we must elect joe biden
and i will tell you i knew joe as vice
president
i knew joe on the campaign trail
and i first got to know joe as the
father
of my friend so joe's son beau
and i served as attorneys general of our
states delaware and california
during the great recession he and i
spoke on the phone nearly
every day working together to win back
billions of dollars for homeowners from
the big banks
that foreclosed on people's homes
and beau would i we would talk about his
family
how as a single father joe would spend
four hours every day riding the train
back and forth
from wilmington to washington
beau and hunter got to have breakfast
every morning
with their dad they went to sleep
every night with the sound of his voice
reading bedtime stories
and while they endured an unspeakable
loss
those two little boys always knew
that they were deeply unconditionally
loved and what also moved me
about joe is the work that he did
as he was going back and forth this is
the leader
who wrote the violence against women act
and enacted
the assault weapons ban who as vice
president
implemented the recovery act which
brought our country
back from the great recessions he
championed
the affordable care act protecting
millions of americans
with pre-existing conditions who spent
decades promoting american values and
interests around
the world joe he believes
we stand with our allies
and stand up to our adversaries
right now we have a president who turns
our tragedies
into political weapons
joe will be a president who turns our
challenges
into purpose joe will bring us together
to build an economy that doesn't leave
anyone behind
where a good paying job is the floor
not the ceiling joe will bring us
together
to end this pandemic and make sure
that we are prepared for the next one
joe will bring us together to squarely
face and dismantle racial injustice
furthering the work of generations joe
and i
believe that we can build
that beloved community one that is
strong
and decent just
and kind one in which we can
all see ourselves
that's the vision that our parents and
grandparents fought for
the vision that made my own life
possible
the vision that makes the american
promise
for all its complexities and
imperfections
a promise worth fighting for
so make no mistake the road ahead is not
easy we may stumble
we may fall short but i pledge to you
that we will act boldly and deal
with our challenges honestly
we will speak truths and we will act
with the same faith in you that we
ask you to place in us
we believe that our country all of us
will stand together for a better future
and we already are we see it in the
doctors the nurses the home
health care workers and frontline
workers who are risking their lives
to save people they've never met we see
it in the teachers and truck drivers the
factory workers and farmers
the postal workers and poll workers
all putting their own safety
on the line to help us get through
this pandemic and we see it in so many
of you
who are working not just to get us
through our current crisis
but to somewhere better
there's something happening all across
our country
it's not about joe or me it's about you
and it's about us people of
all ages and colors and creeds
who are yes taken to the streets
and also persuading our family members
rallying our friends organizing our
neighbors and getting out the vote
and we have shown that when we vote
we expand access to health care
and expand access to the ballot box and
ensure
that more working families can make a
decent living
and i'm so inspired by a new generation
you you are pushing us to realize the
ideals
of our nation pushing us to live
the values we share decency
and fairness justice and love
you are patriots who remind us
that to love our country is to fight
for the ideals of our country
in this election we have a chance
to change the course of history
we're all in this fight you
me and joe together
what an awesome responsibility
what an awesome privilege
so let's fight with conviction
let's fight with hope
let's fight with confidence in ourselves
and a commitment to each other
to the america we know is possible
the america we love
and years from now this moment will have
passed
and our children and our grandchildren
will look in our eyes and they're going
to ask
us where were you when the stakes
were so high they will ask us
what was it like and we will tell them
we will tell them not just how we felt
we will tell them what
we did thank you
god bless you and god bless the united
states of america
beautiful
the books
um
they'll never be happy with them
the things that everyone told me
is
oh
thank you senator harris so powerful to
close out the night we've got some
amazing music from the incomparable
jennifer hudson
as well as some highlights from tonight
and then tomorrow we'll hear from more
americans fighting for a more perfect
union
fighting for all of us and finally joe
biden will officially accept
the nomination for president i'll be
tuning in i hope you will too
thank you for letting me be a part of
your night
this is
me
these
i was
in little tits
oh i am just like the river i've been
running
a long time
to die
well i go
to my brother
please
oh
somehow
it's
me
is
we must elect a president who will bring
something different something better
and do the important work
a president who will bring all of us
together black white latino asian
indigenous
to achieve the future we collectively
want we must
elect joe biden
he was there for me he'll be there for
you too
remember back in 2016 when trump asked
what do you have to lose
well now we know our health care our
jobs
our loved ones our leadership in the
world
and even our post office we come
together now
not to decry the darkness but to light a
way forward
for our country the way i see it big
problems
demand big solutions now
i love a good plan and joe biden has
some really good plans
but here's the thing no single american
can fix this country alone not even a
president
democracy was never meant to be
transactional you give me your vote i
make
everything better it requires an active
and informed citizenry
so i'm also asking you to believe in
your own ability
to embrace your own responsibility as
citizens
to make sure that the basic tenets of
our democracy endure
greetings i am archbishop el pidophoros
of the greek orthodox archdiocese of
america
let us pray most merciful and loving god
as we gather in sovereignness of mind
and of heart
for the sake of our nation and its
future
we pray that you would shine the light
of your countenance
upon the delegates of this convention
and upon vice president joe biden
for the highest office in the land
as we face the future as one american
nation
bring us to our best selves and inspire
our better
angels in peace in fairness
and in generosity that we may fight
against
injustice inequality and hatred
that we may achieve a common good a
greater good
in the name of the holy trinity we pray
amen
that concludes our convention program
for this evening
we will stand in recess until tomorrow
evening
you